[Musique]
maurice duplessis a régné sur le québec
pendant 18 ans un québec encore
profondément agricole
[Musique]
son premier mandat commence en 1936
lorsqu'il défait les libéraux qui était
au pouvoir depuis trente huit ans mais
sa victoire il la doit à son alliance
avec des dissidents libéraux un an plus
tôt en 1935 duplessis d'à peu près
inconnu du plessis c'est simplement un
autre chef conservateur et surtout cet
instant caméléon duplessis ce quelqu'un
que très peu d'idées politiques
il va toujours attaquer le parti libéral
mais en proposant très peu d'idées
nouvelles et eelv a construit sa
popularité justement contre le parti
libéral donc il va coalisée derrière lui
tous les éléments d'opposition
ces dissidents ont fondé l'action
libérale nationale leurs leaders ont été
baptisés les quatre mousquetaires c'est
le journal satirique l'autorité un
journal libéral montréalais qui va leur
donner ce sont nos rangs en premier les
quatre mousquetaires quand on s'appelle
alexandre dumas on n'hésite pas on en
fait un livre quatre mousquetaires de
québec ils sont rené chaloult député
nationaliste oscar drouin organisateur
politique ernest grégoire maire de
québec et un dentiste de québec philippe
hamel le plus important certainement ces
faits les panels qui est vraiment celui
qui va populariser l'idée de
nationaliser l'électricité au québec
pour présenter cela comme la façon de
libérer l'économie canadienne française
allié au parti conservateur l'action
libérale nationale perd de justesse
l'élection de 1935 une fois de plus
truqués par les libéraux
afin de cash flow prêtre monsieur alex h
au cap mode push mid caps lapointe
[Musique]
à partir de là maurice duplessis devient
la vedette du comité des comptes publics
qui démolit l'appareil corrompus des
libéraux du premier ministre alexandre
taschereau quand on en aura fini avec
cette langue est la preuve et ça ne
rimait avec un parti libéral
c'est le pouvoir vous voulez et bien
qu'on ne leur est pas série du plessis
de radio canada
2978 rend ces séances historiques avec
grande fidélité au mans je vous parle ce
taschereau et chez le lieutenant
gouverneur monsieur pas trop pour
remettre sa démission taschereau
démissionne son successeur adélard
godbout déclenché des élections en août
1936 des élections générales auront lieu
le 15 août prochain maurice duplessis le
chef incontesté de l'opposition et fait
du libéral national paul ouin son bras
droit
arrive justement avec un programme de
réformes très ambitieux donc nationalisé
l'électricité des allocations familiales
des pensions vieillesse un code du
travail des mesures qui semblent aller
de soi aujourd'hui mais qui sont vues
comme étant très progressiste presque
communiste à l'époque du plessis h et
tout programme qu'ils signent ou les
islettes heures what prélève c'est
mourir triomphe de l'union nationale
mais maurice duplessis ne tiendra pas
ses promesses comme s la violation de
vie privée
cela crée dans libération des canadiens
françois en privé du plessis va dire que
les promesses c'est bon par les
élections et de les élections sont
terminées trois ans plus tard il faut le
dire carrément il n'y a jamais eu
l'intention de réaliser le programme des
élections de 36
on va oublier les quatre mousquetaires
qui vont lâcher du plessis qui perdra
l'élection de 1939 au début de la guerre
mais il revient au pouvoir en 1945 du
plessis va effectivement imiter
taschereau sur plusieurs plans et va
perfectionner ce qui pouvait faire de
mieux par exemple la corruption
électorale vont être aussi présente chez
duplessis mais elle va être mieux
organisé
la révolution tranquille aurait donc pu
commencer en 1936 il faudra attendre à
la place on a eu la grande noirceur un
régime autoritaire réactionnaire voire
obscurantistes une notion qu'il faut
nuancer les premières mesures dette
sociale qu'on a vu au québec si
duplessis qui les a mises en place
l'électrification des campagnes le
développement d'hydro-québec leur
rapport d'impôt québécois donc il ya
vraiment des mesures très importantes et
très beau stif keynes plessiet mis en
place réélu quatre fois maurice le
noblet duplessis avocats très catholique
de trois rivières a été très populaire
il est décédé dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions 1959
[Musique]